Our full appointment last week, you said to hold off taking Fendezal on your
cheek swab analysis. You haven't listed to take the swab data to give you a change of my
nodal. I just left it on there because we're going to go back on it. I thought we spoke.
I remember this correctly, that when we spoke about the Fendezal we wanted to wait until we
get your blood work back. So I want to look at your blood work before we go back on the Fendezal
also stay off of it until we get that blood work back. So remember if a person's taking Fendezal
we have to make sure that it's not negatively affecting their liver and we would see that
on blood work on a comprehensive metabolic panel, not a basic metabolic panel. So if you're going
into the doctor to get blood work and you have the ability to request what they're going to do,
you want a CBC with differential and a comprehensive metabolic panel at minimum. So anything
less of that is not going to give you an update to make any assessments on anything. I have no idea
why they would run a basic metabolic panel on anyone. So we need to see the liver markers.
So that will tell us that will show us the ALT, AST and alkaline phosphatase, which is essential,
which can be which Fendezal can affect. So that's what I wanted to hold off until we look at that
blood work. What about iburemectin then? Should I continue on that and how often? I don't see that I don't
we haven't seen anything as possible. So iburemectin is still in medication and it can still
possibly adversely affect the liver, but we just haven't seen that. So I have a lot of people
taking iburemectin and it just does not tend to again. Everybody's individual and it could happen
with you, but it does not tend to have the ill effects on the liver as Fendezal can. But remember it's
only about 50% of the people that have the ill effects of the liver with Fendezal, but we have had
almost 0% have ill effects on iburemectin. So I would say you could continue with iburemectin.
How often you should take iburemectin? I didn't test it. I can't legally test the iburemectin
with the cheek swab test. But in general, how often should a person take iburemectin? Well, again,
the frequency is kind of all over the board. The only thing that you can say with certainty with ibure
mectin is if you take too low of a dose, if you're not at a cancer-killing dose, it's really not
beneficial. So remember the dosage for iburemectin, we have it on the members site, the first page,
the home page of the members site, but the dosage for iburemectin is you take your weight in pounds,
convert it to kilograms. So let's say you weigh 50 kilograms. Well, then the starting dose for
iburemectin is 1.5 milligram per kilogram weight. So my starting dose for iburemectin would be 25
milligrams per day. And then you could go up to 1 milligram per kilogram weight. And there are
some people, I don't think I have any current patients that are doing this right now. Some people
can take 1.5 to even 2 milligrams per kilogram weight. That's a lot. But a person's got stage 4
cancer and was given a month to live by their medical doctor. I mean, I would do that.
But if you're not in those dire straits, then I would stay at the starting dose,
or maybe up to 1 milligram per kilogram dose. And then how often do you take it? Now, typically,
with fentanyl, you're pulsing it. You're going like 4 days on, 3 days off, or 3 days on, 4 days off,
or 5 days on, 2 days off, or 2 weeks on, 2 weeks off. And the pulse rate, even though the original
tip-ins protocol for fentanyl was 3 days on, 4 days off. There's people doing all sorts of
different things. And I am patients doing all sorts of different pulses. Some people will do 3 days
on fentanyl, 4 days on iburemectin, and then 3 days off iburemectin and 3 days on fentanyl. So it's
all over the board. So partially, it depends on whether you are, you know, what condition you're
in. If your cancer is growing in a state of rapid replication, then I would hit it harder,
and maybe I would just stay on it. iburemectin is one that you can stay on. But again, I wouldn't
stay on iburemectin like long-term, but it's certainly one that you don't necessarily need to
pulse. Now the negative iburemectin tends to be a little more difficult to get. iburemectin's
prescribed or to get it to have it on hand, so you have to factor that in as well.
And then the question about fentanyl, fentanyl definitely impacted my liver. I had to quit. Dr.
has to be taking iburemectin five days on two days off. Yeah, so we've had a lot of people
that I've had to take off of fentanyl and to pulse it. I would say 50% of the people
that we have go on fentanyl and they can tolerate it just fine. It does not affect their liver
negatively at all, and then 50% it does. And if it does affect your liver, then you either have
to go off of it or pulse it. I mean, most people have been fine just pulsing it. They maybe go on
for two weeks, off for two weeks or on a month, get their liver checked. The numbers have gone up,
then they wait a month, off of it a month to get the check to get it goes down, and then they go on
again. The question that pertains to that, any success with Tadka helping with the liver with
fentanyl. So Tadka is an aid for liver detoxification. So all of my patients that are in
fentanyl are doing something similar to Tadka. If not, Tadka floor helping with that.
And it's just, it doesn't seem, either it's going to affect your liver, it's not going to affect
your liver. All the day in the night root, milk, this will in Tadka and everything that you would
do to help try to flush out the phase one phase two pathway. It doesn't seem to be able to
make a difference. Now, I will also say that the dosage of fentanyl makes a difference too.
People on the original dosage of fentanyl, which was the Jotipin protocol, and the pulse rate of that
was three days on, four days off, and only taking one packet of that, which was equivalent to 222
milligrams of fentanyl, three days a week. So they were only taking 222 milligrams per day, those three
days. So that dosage was lower than what is out there being recommended by people like Dr. William
Backus sometimes will put people in 1,000 milligrams of fentanyl. And I have her back then,
you know, but he's also dealing with making those recommendations for people who maybe are in
more dire straits. We need their cancers growing like crazy and they've been given them up to live.
Again, if I was in that kind of situation, I would go high dose, you know, but when you're not in that
kind of situation, you do want to continue to look at those liver markers because you certainly
doesn't seem to make much sense for a person to die of liver failure, but they've effectively,
killed the cancer that makes no sense. So we have to try to make sense of this and be rational
thinkers as we go through this so that we don't injure ourselves with the therapy.
Don't be clouded in your thinking that, you know, that fentanyl and I've erected
our natural ways to kill cancer, quote-unquote. They're alternative, I would say. They're
alternative to chemotherapy, radiation, surgery, but they're not natural. They're still drugs. So
whereas, you know, you do chemotherapy, which is an oxidizing agent to kill cancer,
kills healthy cells too and causes oxidative stress to healthy cells and could actually be a cause
of cancer. But if you do, you know, B-17, let's say, or you're doing, you know, SCAC or you're doing,
those are natural approaches to a cancer that are going to spare healthy cells and could actually
be beneficial to healthy cells as well. So let's not confuse that, you know, doing fentanyl,
liver back to their quote-unquote, natural. They're alternative, but they're not natural.